ん
バーンん
それが姉と始まんねぇぜ
いやあああああああっ
こんにちはパドル
っていうことでまだちょっと引っ越せしたてなんでまたちょっと
済みとかでまだ続いてるんですけども無事荷物を運び終わりました
とりあえずね前回の部屋の反省点を踏まえていろいろ子を変えたんですよ
まず1部屋だと生活ベアト撮影ベアが一緒になっちゃって動画とるために片付けし
なきゃいけなくて
めっちゃいい曲だったんですよ今回も撮影ベイト生2名
もうちょっと分けてこのヘアーもうドーハ専用というかもう会われる専用みたいな家
です
なんでもこのように関してはもう俺は好きなことしていったわけだえっ
いやぁああああああ弱点としてはコンビニが近くにないです前住んでたようですねもう
家のと前にローソンなんだねおっそい行けたんですよ
労組がコンビニみたいになってたんですよあーする
山村見た高村南殿そこ日に当たってるので僕じゃんローソンが僕んちのコンビニみたい
になってたんですよ
だからもなんか食べ物にも困らなかったし沸かせて遊ぶコミュに入ってなかって帰って
きた宮そういう生活を送ってたんですけどもあるちゃうんですよ
ちょっと遠いんで簡単に行けなくなってしまっただからとてもね食べ物に困ってるわけ
です今そこら辺がちょっとねどうなるかって感じです
ん
おなか空きましたなんでちょっと今何もない状態なんでとりあえず
マジック数千を買ってみるって訳なんですよ
意味わかんないかもよあれないこういう場にこういう風船方を折ったりしてなんか
プードルとか調査とかね
キリンとかフラワーとが作るスペースでこういう音なんかその賛成できるよう額ヘアが
できたのは非常に香ばしい
11動画とるたびに片付けたりしまっていいんだよ最高じゃ的なザマジック支援を
つくってみましょうはこれを作ったことないからね
ません
それが二
メルひどいちゃんのあこれを使ったこれを使ってタブ膨らませるっぽいでこれに風船を
まず取り付けますさあこれでいいんど
抜けないようでございだから追求入れます
止めた遅いなここだけ膨らんだけどして何で
なにこれこっち同線のこれはぼっちだしちゃうかも知れた
難なくすごいなぁの部分的にクラブからびっくりするを
暇な日
ん
えっ俺死んでねえ部屋は作れましたん
なんだがんば者がおかしいもモーション言い残し
すっ
ベッドああああっ保寧子3回目なんだけどおっしゃって本当的に何か作って終わります
動画的に何か作っております
何と喋ってロガーまで空気がいたないんですよねなんだこれ
エアーなやなお家まで行ってこれで釣れないよ
さあ
これヤバイぞ何が作らなきゃ動画でくれますじゃない今度はミスラ戦争
me
あああ
ああああああああ
it けど僕の作品ですカマキリですありがとうございました